[Music]
and i started to feel unsafe so i ended
up telling him that i lost the baby and
so now you got to now that baby's 10
months old huh
yeah i can't imagine feeling like my
child and my safety were so much so that
i had to be on the run
what up what up this is john with the dr
john dolone's show we're talking about
marriage and parenting and mental health
and whatever else is going on in your
world and in your life we hope that you
are doing well
uh if you want to be on the show give me
a buzz at
three 1-844-693 two ninety one it's one
eight four four six nine three three two
nine one
uh leave a message and let us know
what's going on and we'll get back in
touch with you also please don't forget
to uh
like this show on whatever device that
you're consuming it on or go leave a
review if it's a negative review please
go to i love
kelly
gmail.com i actually have no idea whose
account that is but that'd be super
funny if y'all blew blew that account up
in fact don't do that that would be rude
there's some sweet person named kelly um
but uh yeah leave some good reviews on
there and i'd be very very grateful also
huge news
for the uh he can't keep this up forever
you're right
congratulations america you win
actually it's not even america is china
i think china congratulations universe
that's the great jim halpert said you
win
so
it's no secret uh my wife tells me i was
born in the wrong century regularly and
so i didn't have social media before i
took this job and i was about six months
into having a youtube show before i knew
i had a youtube show and that i still
don't fully understand what a youtube
channel is but i got one of those too
so i've got somebody who helps me with
social media his name is zach and
um all the things that we post are
things that came out of my mouth like
things i said um but he i don't know how
to log into some of these platforms um i
know how to get onto to instagram but he
takes the content he puts it up in other
places
and he's been saying dude you need to do
tick tock
and i was like well a i'm not 13 and b i
don't dance well
and um c
it gives me hemorrhoids and
he was like i know but a it doesn't give
you hemorrhoids that's just you um not
eating properly or being stressed a lot
and
b
it's
it's really good and there's it's does
there is there's a lot of good that it
does
so i said all right man
go to the tick tocks
here we come tick tocks so he posted a
video yesterday
and it's how what is it now it's like
1.1 1.2 million people it went viral
it's so ridiculous
we've gone viral kelly you
and me were tick-tock sensations
i think it's more you
since i'm not in it you're coming with
me sister
we are we are tick tock sensations
together so you can uh
i don't know how to get there i would go
to ticktock.com.net
ticktock.org
okay so
for those because this is making no
sense whatsoever
john has a tick tock account at john
delony at john follow me at john colony
and it's it's it's
blowing up we had our first huge uh
video but hey hold on at john de loni's
my phone number for all the other
platforms
just go with it that's the point yeah
you want to be so they can find you
anywhere that was incredible ben that's
the point
hey follow follow me on tick tock
at john dalone sarah you're probably
gonna edit all that out aren't you
um she's like absolutely hundred percent
edit all that out hey uh tick tock
sensation america
hold on to your hats
hey let's do this let's go to uh emmy in
nashville what's up emmy
hi dr john how are you i was man
i'm doing fantastic and i'm not very
good at this radio thing do you have
tick-tock
i don't i don't really have social media
so oh i think i need to call your show
because i need help
need help okay so what's up what's going
on
um so my main question is how do i get
out of my own way so
so i can achieve my professional and
personal goals
um so i'll stop there and then um i
don't know if you want to stop me or
tell me more tell me more
okay so
i have to take certain certifications um
for my job so i'll start with the job
and then i'll go to the personal side
so for my job i've had certifications
and up until this point
they've gone really really well but i've
hit a roadblock
and i would say that for the last couple
of years i've been taking these
certifications i have a habit of
starting many fires for lack of a better
term so that way i can give myself this
like emotional boost so that way like oh
well i fixed my problem
and then like i move on i do well on the
certification i move on
um but now it's getting to the point
where it's my last certification this is
the end and i just can't seem to pass it
so it's not necessarily that i don't
know the material it's just these mini
fires are no longer helping me
um in a lot of the different
like anger or fear motivators that i
used to have that would really focus in
on
my work are now just being
distractionary
and it's just it's really messing me up
and
i'm starting to have like physical
ramifications and so like now i get like
physically sick every time i go to these
certifications
um and so it's just getting really out
of hand and i need to figure out better
ways of handling this dress or getting
myself over this uh adventure awesome um
one thanks for sharing that
uh that's
a tough sled in there um
i'm assuming that you don't want to do
you mind telling me what what
certification you're looking for or give
me a general is it tax is it health care
is it something like what's what's the
general field
uh data science so it's a lot of like
computer programming and just like
finance content okay and so let's say
you pass your exam tomorrow what do you
go do
next
uh
for the industry that's pretty much it
like i i get a fancy letter
um and that's pretty much it um it's
it's technically just to prove that like
i am capable of doing something
um and like i do it every day so it's
obviously not necessary but it does
translate to
possible promotions in the future
okay
um
tell me about your life
um i would say that i'm kind of high
strong
you don't stop at me you don't say
um and
i have to say like in my personal life
um
i'm very
oriented when it comes to goals
so i'm very good at getting from point a
to point b
with the exception of point b meaning
what i actually want to do
um so
for example say i want to start dating
and stuff like that and then i like meet
someone i like and then i get
self-conscious i gain 40 pounds and then
i stop talking to them because i feel
uncomfortable with myself gotcha um and
then i lose the weight again i finally
feel good about myself and then it
happens all over again tell me about
growing up talking about your folks
oh no they're they're great um really
low-key we're really close and stuff
like that um very supportive family
um
how long have you how long has have you
struggled with this
this is something that's been around for
a long time right
yeah i would say that it
got worse when i left college i don't
know if like actually having
responsibility like true real
responsibility ramification just kind of
slapped me in the face
um but i would say that probably since i
was in like elementary school middle
school i've always had issues
um with
confidence with um
kind of feeling great about myself and
not self-sabotaging when you say great
about yourself are you talking about
appearance are you talking about people
loving you talking about
people
you you feeling like they were in your
corner
um yeah i would definitely say outside
my family i've never really felt like
i can
trust what people think of me
um and i kind of
my year of reflection i think it's just
like i'm
putting my own self-feelings onto them
and so if i'm feeling uncomfortable with
myself i'm interpreting them being
uncomfortable with me
um and i just i listen to a lot of
distraction and noise and even though
like i have my family in my corners i'm
like no no no like
you're fine like this is not an issue
like stop listening to other people
i just get distracted
and i get self-conscious and
i listen to the wrong people um and then
it it really wrecks havoc on my
confidence and myself
who told you
that you let me just say this okay i'm
gonna lob a grenade and you can
fall on it you can say that's stupid or
you can just throw it back at me is that
cool
how old are you
i'm 28. okay
um
it's not uncommon
when somebody is walking through what
you're struggling with okay
and
they tell me that they have a great
relationship with their family
sometimes often
that means that a they have a very safe
defined role in that family
and or that family has provided them
with care and comfort and all of the
answers to life's challenges
so what i mean by that is sometimes it
is a
mom would get upset and i know how to
take care of mom
or i know how to take care of dad or
there was an issue in their marriage a
long time ago and i was able to help
with the brothers and sisters whatever
like i have a very defined purpose there
or
um why don't you go ask your father your
dad will help you with that um you just
need to ask your mom oh i don't think
you should go to that school and that
was
a
covert way of saying you are absolutely
not going to that school do any of those
ring a bell
um kind of the first i would say that i
didn't necessarily have a role
but it was definitely the family over an
individual and so
we work as a unit for the betterment of
this family and so
and what happened it was always about
the family not any individual person
was always about the family about what
mom and dad wanted to do
or one of them in particular here here's
what i'm getting at i don't want to pull
your family apart here on just a short
phone call here's what i'm getting at
number one somebody told you a long time
ago and they demonstrated this
over and over and over again that emmy
is to not be trusted
emmy cannot rely on emmy emmy's got to
rely on us
and that's why i point back to
usually that starts with your parents
um
you oh honey that's just a stupid thing
you need to do it like this or you don't
look good in that shirt you need to
dress like this
who would even wear that kind of
comments the second thing is is somehow
you translated that okay and again this
is as a child so it's not like a blame
thing this is just an either or
into i know how i can get people to
tell me i've got value to show me i've
got value and that's through achievement
and performance
and then you get out on your own
and you achieve one thing
and you still don't like who you see in
the mirror or more importantly you don't
trust yourself still and so you try to
achieve again and try to achieve again
and you keep pushing that line
and now you're at the end of a
track and your body knows you're not
safe
so much so that it doesn't want you to
take that exam and it's going to make it
so physically sick so you don't
because
not passing an exam means not like it
would for me like oh man i screwed up or
i didn't study that hard or i'm just
dumb i didn't get it
it means to you
i am nothing
so that that's the general usual arc
tell me if i'm off somewhere
oh no that's that's
the end goal is definitely kind of what
happened and i definitely developed the
mindset that
like if i don't achieve um so yeah i
would say that that's very very accurate
i my concern is
again if i haven't spent a lot of time
with you my concern is that your
safety inside of your family
has become enmeshment
their air is your air and your air is
their air
or if you were just to announce hey i'm
moving to south dakota i got a great
opportunity to be a programmer there i'm
28 i'm single i'm unattached i'm going
to go live a crazy life i've got a job
in los angeles california i'm going to
live in a high-rise and i'm just going
to live it up for two years
that there would be a disruption to
their plans
is that accurate or not accurate
um
or they say
a little bit so my first reaction is
like oh no that's not true but
i think i'm also kind of seeing things
through rose-colored glasses because
i guess i would consider myself extreme
extreme ownership so if i'm in the room
and something happens it has to be my
fault if i wasn't there then it wouldn't
have happened okay that's not extreme
ownership
extreme ownership means when you are
leading a thing
you take responsibility for the outcome
it doesn't mean if you are abused you're
responsible for other people feeling
uncomfortable
extreme ownership is not
um hey you've been trained over the
course of 15 20 30 years that your voice
doesn't count or it's less than
everybody else's
and you need to go do this thing
and then you find yourself responsible
for everyone's feelings and thoughts
what you are as a peacekeeper not an
extreme owner
extreme ownership would say
uh i have this exam
i love sunday lunches i'm not going to a
sunday lunch until i pass this exam
because i really want this thing to be
done
and i want to do it really well
and i'm not going to care about my
feelings i'm going to create a very
strong
um
schedule i'm going to stick to it no
matter what
every day i'm just going to get up and
do it i'm going to do it i'm going to do
it and then if i fail i'm going to take
ownership i did everything i could
and that i knew to do and i'm gonna go
get some coaching and i'm gonna go back
and do it again you see you see the
difference there
yeah a peacekeeper feels responsible for
everybody else's feelings because they
were told your feelings come last
that make sense
yeah and what i really i really want
emmy's feelings
to come first
do you even want to be a programmer
um
i mean
no no
no
no that's what i'm good at it doesn't
matter i'm good at painting bedrooms i
don't want to do that for a living
i'm really good like i'm really talented
i'm good at mowing like i'm good at it i
can make a yard look really nice i do
not want to do that for a living
i can make a lot of money mowing i've
got a buddy that runs a lawn care
business he does well i don't do that
for a living what do you want to do
i have no clue
i'm being honest i have literally no
flow and unfortunately i guess i've lost
part of
like
exploration like i kind of it's not an
art it's a desire
yeah who told you to quit exploring
somebody told you this stuff emmy
i hear a sense of adventure in you
and i hear a sense of resignation
that this is just the way this is gonna
be
yeah and that's kind of what i'm trying
to get myself out is i recognize the
fact that
doing nothing or accepting like this is
it like it's not healthy and like i
there's so much
i want
to be
happy with
but it's just like i when i do achieve
it
like what does that mean like i'm still
stuck with myself yeah wherever you go
there you go you'll go with you right
yeah
and so it's making peace with who you
see in the mirror
and then deciding
hey is this what i want to do b what i
really want to do who do i want to be
and by the way i can keep plugging along
because i'm freaking emmy and i'm
awesome
i do good work i'm a good person a
character
and then it's making some really
hard but
um simple you know and you know the
difference there right like how do you
lose weight and exercise well that's
really simple but it's super hard to do
um i'm going to make some really hard
but simple choices when it comes to
i've got an exam coming up so this is
i'm going to study like this even when i
don't want to
and i'm going to put the time and the
effort in because this is the last time
i'm going to take this exam
and i'm going to eat healthy and i'm not
going to self sabotage on those moments
that i feel like i'm about to i'm going
to have somebody that i reach out to and
then i call
and i'm making it sound really simple
and at the end of the day we overthink
it because it is i'm just going to not
do those things
or i'm not going to take that last exam
it's not going to take it
i don't want to be doing this job i'm
tired of this job i i don't you know
what i mean it's like getting to the end
of uh
mara a mile 20 in the marathon
and be like what am i doing i don't want
to do this okay
if you
picture yourself i mean you just quit
you just stop the tests like you're like
dude i'm not am i doing this for a
certificate for an achievement that i
don't care that i even have for a job
that i don't even really want
like if you just stopped does that give
you peace or does that give you anxiety
i don't even know how i feel
a farm is like oh man like you were so
close just finish it just for the fact
that you say to yourself you're a
finisher you don't quit when things get
hard
um but i've also i got into this role
because someone told me now that i think
about it i got into this role because
someone told me oh you won't be good at
it and i had to prove to them no no no
i'll be good at it i'll show you yeah
yeah yeah and so now i'm here so that
obviously the only person that needs to
watch it is me
well and
it sounds like you've outsourced
your feelings and thoughts to a degree
where
i mean i mean you're living like a life
of like almost instagram quotes
and you're judging yourself against them
like you're a 3d living and breathing
member of my community here in nashville
like you're on my team you're one of us
like we may have like sat by each other
in a coffee shop for crying out loud you
know what i mean like
it's yes extreme ownership is good
that's not what's happening here
ownership first looks in the mirror and
says like i'm going to own how i think
and how i feel and i'm going to own my
value and it's high
like and i'm not going to create an
entire trajectory of my life with a
middle finger in my rear view mirror
because
man that's an exhausting way to live
here's what i'm gonna do i'm gonna send
you a couple of things okay
um
actually can i make a real bold
statement
just yeah and i want you when you hang
up the phone i want you to be like that
guy's an idiot okay if i'm wrong
um
the first thing i'm gonna send you is
i'm gonna send you a copy of my book
okay own your past change of future
here's why
i don't fully buy your story
um
i can count on maybe one hand and just a
few fingers the number of times that
someone's told me a similar situation to
what you're working through
that isn't carrying a lot of
garbage from their childhood
whether it was the best way i can find
um get mom and dad to
leave me alone or to
get their approval or to get their nod
of um you're okay today it was to get
straight a's or i need to get your
attention by going and do something
bananas behavior is a language and
something about
your language like do you love me do you
love me do you love me as achievement
accomplishment accomplishment
achievement achievement i'll make sure
everybody's okay
i'm just gonna stay here in the nest i'm
never gonna jump out and fly
and so i'm gonna send you that you can
hang up the phone and be like dude my
family is perfect deloney quit trying to
dig into my past just everything's fine
um
i i would challenge you on that but
that's for another phone call so i'm
gonna send you that the second thing i'm
gonna send you is my buddy ken coleman
has a career assessment it's a it's a
thing you take online it's digital thing
and it helps
point you in the direction of what do
you actually want to do what do you
actually care about it's called a get
clear assessment i'm going to send you a
free one of those too i'm also going to
send you my buddy ken i'm going to say
the same guys ken's book paycheck to
purpose where you can sit down and go
okay i'm making a living i'm doing this
coding thing
what do i want to do i'm officially a
quarter of the way through
right no probably a third i'm a third of
the way through
and i am
i'm getting out of here like i'm i'm
gonna go do something that i really
wanna do i wanna go be a part of let's
figure figure out what that is when it
comes to the exam i'm like you you're
this close i'd finish
but i think i would take the emotion and
the stuff and strip it away and say
i am i am emmy and i'm a good person and
i love myself and i love my life whether
i fail this test or not i'm gonna go
take this test i'm gonna pass this test
i'll move on with my day
and really take the drama out of it and
it sounds so simple and uh do it it is
it is i'm gonna create a structure and a
strategy and go get done
thanks for calling me um
i think there's a wide open space for
you to go running
wide open and it's one of those moments
where you can back up and just change
everything we'll be right back
it seems like everybody's talking about
how crazy the housing market is right
now and how powerless homebuyers feel
mix that with the stress of moving and
life change and job change and you've
got a tornado of anxiety fueling one of
the biggest purchases you'll ever make
this is not a good idea so if you're a
new home buyer right now my advice to
you is to focus on what you can control
like the people you choose to help you
in the home buying process
you need folks like my friends at
churchill mortgage churchill is a ramsey
trusted provider that's been helping
people with their home mortgages for
decades and their home buyer edge
program will help you skip a bunch of
the stress here's how it works apply to
become a churchill certified home buyer
and cap your interest rate for 90 days
then you'll get a 5 000 seller guarantee
to help your offer stand out so go ahead
take a deep breath because churchill has
your back check them out at
churchillmortgage.com
delony and get the homebuyer edge today
this is a paid advertisement in mls id
1591 nmls consumeraccess.org equal
housing lender 1749 mallory lane suite
100 brentwood tennessee 37027 programs
are for select loan types only and are
not available in all states or locations
all right we're back let's go to
elizabeth in austin what's up elizabeth
hey how you doing i'm good how are you
i'm hanging in there oh no what's going
on
well okay so i have a 10 month old son
um 34 years old and
i had dated his father for
four months and he revealed to me after
that time that he did two years in
prison for uh physically assaulting his
ex-girlfriend and i was starting to
notice he was being verbally abusive and
starting to throw things so
i found out i was pregnant unexpectedly
and i started to feel unsafe so i tried
to figure out how to get out of it so i
ended up telling him that i lost the
baby
oh
and so now you gotta now that baby's 10
months old huh
so how can i help
um i mean i'm basically just like
wondering why i keep thinking about it
pretty much on a daily basis
and i'm also worried about
when my son gets older you know what is
he gonna
i mean when he asked me where's my dad
at you know i don't know what to tell
him because i don't want to lie to him
so number one
um
okay i'm gonna i'm just gonna say all
the things out at the same time is that
okay
sure
um
as the father of a child
i can't imagine feeling like my
child and my safety were so much so that
i had to be on the run
so every moment you open your eyes
because your body's on the run you're on
the run okay
you're hiding from someone that you're
scared of
and you're hiding from someone that is
you are now linked to forever
and um
yeah and
the safety of your kid so that's number
one
also as the father of two little kids
the thought that someone would hide a
child from me i can't like that creates
a rage it carries such an anger at me
that it's almost overwhelming right so
my first thought is like what do you
mean you didn't tell him like he doesn't
know he's got a kid right and i'm
balancing that with
yeah you weren't in that room john and
so i want to trust you elizabeth that
you're not safe and that you weren't
safe okay
um
and it wasn't only that there was other
things as well you know
like what
he lived he lived two and a half hours
away from me and um
he
fell asleep at the wheel at least twice
that i know of because we had a major
argument the night that i ended up you
know wanting to break up with him and
he had texted me that hour and a half
later after we had the argument it's
like oh i fell asleep again and went
into a ditch
and i'm like
i couldn't imagine him driving my baby
in the car and then falling asleep
because he at least done it twice as far
as i know
so so
a hundred percent i understand what
you're saying okay like i'm don't i'm
not here to i'm not i'm not shaming a
mom keeping her baby safe
and that's his baby too
right i understand that so it's it's a
mess it's just a mess is what it is it's
just an absolute mess
um
and then the third thing here to just
lob on top of all this is your instinct
is correct with the internet there is no
such thing as a kid who doesn't find out
yeah that happens sooner or later and if
if you're a parent who doesn't tell the
truth to him
not only does he find out who his dad is
he also
finds out mom
is tells lies
right and then he begins to wonder does
mom love me because she said that a lot
and his mom believed this and his mom do
right so it undermines the the sidewalk
with which he will walk on your son
and i don't know
have you checked into the legality of it
i know it's state to state states are
different um
some states it's illegal to do what
you're doing
other states it's like a gray area it's
only illegal if he wants into the baby's
life
and you prevent it but if you told them
that the baby's not around you see what
i'm saying
yeah
um
here's what i would do if i were you
i would reach out to an attorney
and say here's what i've done here's why
i did it i need some some guidance
because right now you are flying blind
and that's keeping you up and that's
stressing you out
um and
that stress is is being absorbed by that
little 10 month old
that true is that right
i mean i i guess what what's the what's
the possibility that you call this guy
and say hey i lied to you
you've got a 10 month old son um i want
you to sign full custody over to me
we're not getting back together i don't
want you to be a part of this baby's
life you have no interest in being
what do you say okay that sounds great
or would he start weeping and say i
can't believe i have a son i'm moving
i have no idea because he already moved
on he's got a girlfriend and she's got
two kids okay
um
well then it may be she fights for
custody right so who knows what kind of
mess this is going to turn into what you
need is some security and you don't have
that right now because you you took off
and i'm not blaming you for taking off
okay that's a whole other
like we're just dealing with where we
are right now your body's in fight or
flight because you were literally on the
run
and
until you get some stability you know
where you sit legally you know where you
sit when it comes to rights and
responsibilities when you know what you
have to do what versus what you're what
you don't have to do
um until you do that your body's going
to be running it's just rather than
revving and rubbing and revving
and you know as well as i do this is a
time bomb there's a reckoning at some
point
anytime there's a reckoning coming i
like to just go get it done
with a team with a gang right
and what i say by reckoning there's a mo
there will come a time
when you have to face this man
and tell him that you hit his child from
him
i mean i didn't want to do that i i had
to
think about it for at least a week
because i mean i knew it was
it's not what i wanted to do i i i know
i know that don't hear me shaming you
okay am i trying i'm not trying to pile
on okay
i mean his reaction was hey you know
let's either give up the baby for
adoption
or get an abortion i didn't want to do
that i wanted to keep my baby that's
right
and i 100 applaud you so the chances of
him giving the baby up signing away
maybe 99
right and maybe he gets a letter from an
attorney
that says we're you are the parent of
such and such and we are requesting full
custody etc um may be great
maybe signs that thing and then you
exhale
right
and then you tell that baby um when he's
older your daddy wasn't well
and um your son will have to live with
the fact that his dad didn't want
anything to do with his life
right um so there's gonna be it's gonna
be hell to pay down the road anyway what
we don't want this baby to to know is
dad left me and mom lied to me the whole
time or dad so badly wanted to be in my
life and mom hid him from me
you know and
a seven year old a 14 year old an 18
year old isn't going to understand hey
mom found out dad was like a violent
criminal
and
he was starting to show signs of those
tendencies around me and i was pregnant
with you and so i got us out of there
keep it safe
that's something maybe a 21 year old 25
year old
um
you see what i'm saying so the the
conversation's coming i'd much rather
you have an attorney you have all the
answers that you need have all the
things lined up and all the paths
forward
and you not live in fear of this day
coming whenever it's going to come
right
you will just sleep so much better even
if you get answers that you don't like
even if the attorney says i'm so sorry
but you gotta call that guy within 24
hours
yeah
at least you'll have some next step
because right now this your whole i mean
you're not sleeping are you
i mean
yeah i mean
like a baby and hey maybe that's the
case maybe that's the case maybe like no
dude i don't know what you're talking
about i did the right thing i'm never
gonna feel a second of bad about it i
did what was right
um but you wouldn't be caught
i mean i feel like i did what i had to
do to keep my son safe but if not
ultimately what i wanted i would have
liked to stay with him if he hadn't been
violent you know absolutely they haven't
been yelling at me all the time yes and
you're gonna have to grieve that
right because uh the dream we have is to
have kids and have this little home on
the picket fence and the dog and the
camping trips like
that picture's not going to happen here
right and so
there will come a moment when we have to
grieve that that comes after you're safe
and right now you're still alone you're
still not registering as safe
you're on the run
so will you reach out to an attorney
yeah i will okay let's call a local
family attorney and say i need to set up
a consultation
and
just sit down and do not please don't go
in there and not tell the whole truth
tell everything that happened all of the
truth
um don't hide anything don't put
anything in a drawer like this is
everything husband's not safe he was
passing out behind the wheel he was um
raising his voice he was throwing us
around he was pushing whatever was going
on um tell the truth
and then they'll walk you through what
comes next
i'm
sorry
i hate this for you i hate this for that
little baby i even hate it for dad i
hate it for everybody it's a mess it's a
mess
but the day of that conversation will
come so let's have that conversation on
near terms
with all the facts and data that you
have and somebody like an attorney on
your side
whenever it all comes down thank you so
much for the call we'll be right back
we are back on yet another
episode of the tick tock sensational
kelly daniels show
do you have a tick tock account kelly
no i'm on it because my son is but no i
do not have a tech talk
i think you should get a tick tock
channel no thank you
although i might dance better than you
there's a hundred percent chance
i challenge you to a tick-tock dance-off
oh i kick your butt up and down the
block consider it happening america i
danced
let's talk about that
where'd you dance kelly
this is gonna be amazing let's go to
dalton in austin hey dalton what's up
dude
hi dr john how are you i'm good brother
what's up
well not much um
so my wife and i are starting to
miscommunicate more
and i want to know how do i take steps
to improve our conversations and
end the unnecessary fighting or maybe
better yet why is it happening
tell me more about it how long you all
been married
uh almost a year we're coming up on our
one-year anniversary okay um
what are y'all fighting about
well
i i would say they're big fights over
very little things like incredibly
nuanced inconsequential
non-important
things um i would say this never used to
happen in all the two and a half years
that we dated
um
man none of that matters anymore
yeah yeah i know i know yeah totally are
you
yeah we argue over the little thing
itself and then we argue about how we
just argued trying to decide what went
wrong and where there was a
miscommunication and trying to solve the
problem
um and it just leads to a lot of hurt
feelings uh in the end because someone
has to be right someone must be wrong
and
my concern is that these have been
increasing in number in the last month
and so when i asked my wife when she
thinks they started she told me i've
been doing something maybe wrong or
insensitive or situation worthy
that could lead to the situation
almost every other day for the last
seven months and that she's only just
recently started bringing it to light or
she ignores it or brushes it off
normally
and that scares the heck out of me
because i don't want to be
consistently putting my wife in a
situation where
you know she feels on edge or where we
are about to fight and i just don't know
it you know it's it's like i've created
an unsafe
environment for her well maybe maybe
maybe um
maybe what's the things what is she
saying that you do to that creates an
unsafe environment
well she hasn't said those words exactly
that's me
being concerned okay i can give an
example a little thing give me an
example what's the thing that she said
you've been doing for seven months that
makes it
um that drives her crazy
um well the thing itself
that i've been doing is i guess just
uh like potentially or starting
small little fights without knowing it
um it's kind of hard to pinpoint um
can i just give my example yeah
sure so i wanted to leave for a movie at
a certain time we were hanging out with
my family
and so everyone was
leaving a little bit later than we had
planned uh five to ten minutes later
when everyone was getting ready to leave
she wanted to run back in and look for a
sweater she was gonna be cold which
would have made us even later
i was a little annoyed and told her
about it so we discussed we tried to
figure out whether i was wrong for
rushing her when we were already late or
whether she was wrong potentially making
us slightly later
while we resolved that part of the
argument fairly quickly we then started
talking about why we miscommunicated
she felt i wasn't listening to her i
felt she wasn't listening to me and so i
got frustrated and raised my voice which
i really do
after that discussion ends we were both
left you know kind of hurt and feeling
like man we never used to fight like
this there was no true resolution you
know she was upset because i didn't
handle the situation perfectly
i'm upset because i didn't handle the
situation perfectly and she was hurt by
it
and so something incredibly
inconsequential about
whether we were going to be late for a
movie which by the way we had planned to
leave so early that we were going to
catch the previews before the previews
you know like we weren't even going to
be late to the movie that didn't matter
at all then why'd you start a fight
i wasn't trying to
that's not what i asked that's not what
i asked why'd you start a fight
i brought it up because there is a
pattern of
my wife
making us slightly late for things we're
leaving slightly later than
i would like to and so that's the only
reason i brought it up but my intention
was never to hold on a second hold on a
second okay hold on a second
this has nothing to do with the time
of course this has to do with power
and
the way you use words
um
i didn't do it perfectly
or she's got to have
it's
very much like talking to an annoyed
parent
okay
and
there's something about her that you
married
i mean let me just ask you is she a
capable adult
yes she's incredibly does she have a job
she does does she do well at the job or
is she always getting in trouble about
the job you see what i'm saying like
she excels she's incredible so what is
it about her that you feel the need to
parent her
or to make her her 2.0 or to improve
some things
i really don't think i feel that need dr
jones but that's what you do
right
so where's that coming from
it's
possibly
my desire to
i guess fix problems as i see them
within the relationship and if i'm the
one that sees the problem i i think oh i
i need to take the step to bring it up
so we can address it so we can resolve
it so we can move on okay so let's let's
let's take that exact thing
when you want to fix a problem
you look externally towards the problem
right and the problem is her and her
timeliness
and by the way
this is a super common first year second
year marriage thing so i want you to
think y'all are crazy your marriage is
over it's none of that
right it is gonna take you not being
arrogant and you being taking a knee
okay here's what i mean
you want to go to fix a problem
and then she is the problem because
she's late
and she repeatedly makes you slightly
late
that's not the problem
the problem is either you like being in
control
the problem is like you like the
appearance of
we are all we have it together and so
we're always on time
another one is this
i was always late to church always
always
and my wife would say let's go let's go
and i was like and finally one day she
said this
she said john
i feel completely exposed when i walk
into our small little church and
everyone turns to see who's walking in
late
i feel exposed and embarrassed and i
don't like everybody looking at me
and when you're late you force me into a
position
of this
so the problem was her
and she was saying i'm addressing this
now so i'm going to start taking my own
car without you
or you can be a part you see what i'm
saying and i have not been late since
because i'll be damned if i'm gonna
embarrass my wife see what i'm saying
and so you
ending up late ending up late ending up
late is not about ending up late
it's about you having the courage to
tell your wife
hey when we're late to things
i feel fill in the blank
that's making the problem about you not
about her she is not up something you
can fix like an engine
that's why i'm using language like
trying to make her 2.0 like upgrade
version of herself
you can't fix her
you can't communicate and say hey this
is how this makes me feel and she can
say
hey when i'm going to be cold
i'd rather be three minutes late than
cold for two hours
right right
that is different than well you did this
right so she's got some culpability here
too
also it probably uh well i just say my
when i found out that i've been doing
something for a year or two years or ten
years that's frustrating or annoying
i felt deceived i felt like my wife
should have told me that
and then i had to ask have i created an
unsafe environment in this home where
you can't even tell me that that you
don't like it where i put my shoes
like is that where we are and then my
wife had to take ownership and say no i
needed to tell you that and so now it's
right away
you see what i'm saying so it's both in
so as when i said maybe um
i think there's a
fairness
hey you're getting onto me about this
and this has been happening for two or
three weeks not seven months because now
it's past the thing and now we feel like
we've been deceived but you see what i'm
getting at all these none of these
fights have anything to do with fights
it has to do with with someone's got to
be right and someone's got to be wrong
and what i would tell you is and you've
probably heard this marriage advice
before you can choose to be right or you
can choose to be wrong or you can choose
to be married
right
anytime if you're right and she's wrong
you both lose
and vice versa
right
and i would tell you that the moment
that you're three minutes late is the
absolute worst time ever to have that
conversation
because it's instantly emotional she's
already feeling upset embarrassed rushed
whatever you're feeling mad and so it's
never going to be a productive
conversation it's going to be a
conversation about emotions not about
how do we how do we make some changes
and grow and heal here see what i'm
saying
i do
i i think my question is
moving forward
is there something i should maybe keep
in mind
when little things like this pop up
in order to avoid
i don't know me creating an issue
i
i am like i don't like to lose right so
i i know that i don't like to lose
arguments but then never ever ever have
one
because that attitude will destroy your
marriage it will end it right dalton end
it right so don't have them
right
and
my wife and i
love
to have these types of discussions is
part of our problem
there like i then it's just about
context
so it's like once a week my wife and i
have our calendar budget meeting
and
that's that's when we talk about these
things because it's a rather unemotional
time it's like eight o'clock on a sunday
or something like that like it's it's an
unemotional time and we're just it's a
very nuts and bolts hey by the way
last week you said you were going to be
here at wednesday and you were going to
take care of dinner you didn't
this is going to be the whole every
wednesday for the rest of semester
here's what dinner looks like and i'll
be like yeah i totally screwed that up
or i'll say oh why don't you tell me and
we had that discussion we move on but
it's not a who's gonna win this and you
should have told me no why why would i
fight i'm not gonna fight i'm not gonna
fight there's no reason to fight
right
and again i'm being facetious
occasionally there's a reason to but
they're so rare right man so rare you
know what i mean though
right i i think we both
know i mean my wife and i both know that
like
the things that we're fighting over
don't matter then stop
like you're overthinking it man stop
like when she's three minutes late why
do you have to have that conversation
right then why
i guess i don't have to yeah yeah look
at this guy dude you're gonna be married
a long time
that's the plan yes
so don't have a conversation until later
until everybody's chill
maybe keep a small little thing on your
phone or a little note to yourself
or if it's still not that big of a deal
an hour later then ta-da that's wisdom
but don't feel like you got to go to war
over everything man
and especially
if you have the thought i need to fix
this
or anytime you think that how about this
anytime you think the thought if she
would just
do not say anything keep that to
yourself
right because that's not a statement
that's not a thought pattern that's not
an emotion that's going towards solving
a problem that's a that's a trajectory
towards victory
and i'll say it again if y'all get into
an argument with the objective that one
of us has to be right one of us has to
be wrong you will both lose a hundred
percent of those arguments
you're right that makes sense
and
you kind of this is back from earlier
you kind of kind of hinted around it a
little bit
never raise your voice don't yell don't
be that guy
you're right okay that's
that's not typically
what i do i was just frustrated and that
was a moment of weakness that's fair
completely agree but when you get
frustrated yeah when you get frustrated
say hey i'm gonna take a break for a
second i can't take a break
and that that's wisdom and restraint and
adult responsibility right it's just
being a grown-up
but here's so if i'm you here's what i
do right now i would take my wife out to
dinner
okay and i would tell her i'm sorry
i'm trying to find my place here i want
to be a great husband i want to have
this presentation of our family we're
always on time and everything's always
not neatly pressed and
where we look to part and do the part
and i want to do so good
and what i'm ended up doing is starting
a lot of fights
and a lot of well if you would's and if
this woods and whatever and i'm sorry
i'm not gonna fight you anymore
i would like to set up like a recurring
once a week where we get coffee together
my wife and i we used to i said we'd do
a budget meetings now we started doing
two mile i mean two hour
uh walks in the morning on saturday
mornings we leave the kids they're old
enough now we just head off into we head
off on these long walks they're
fantastic
but we talk about everything man i get
animated and i can be like because i'm a
lot right
i can do all those things but they're
not threatening we're on the same side
as we're walking like we're facing the
same direction together
it just changes the whole tenor so we're
still talking with some communications
but i'm just not gonna fight
so here's a good example um when she
goes to bed she doesn't let the dogs in
and i gotta let take the dogs and take
them down the set of stairs into the
basement where they stay and
at 11 o'clock at night when i'm getting
home from something and i'm tired and
the dogs are still out that is not the
time to have that conversation
at nine o'clock when i look into our
bedroom and she's already um
reading and that's not the time to have
that conversation
she's not
when we're going for our walks on sunday
mornings or i mean on saturday mornings
or having our budget meetings where i
can say hey in the evenings it would be
a make up it's be a big deal for me if
you were going to put the dogs away when
you go ahead and
when you turn the lights off and do xyz
see how different of a conversation that
is and she could say by the way you
don't do anything how about you get the
dogs and i'd say all right that's well
done and then it's my job i don't have
to fight about anymore see how much how
simpler that is
yes i do okay
um does she love you
she does yes a lot
yes can you just can you rest in that
yes i think i can
can i tell you this it took me like 20
20 years that's not true probably 16 17
years to figure out how to do that
so this isn't something you can do over
time
she loves you man you're anchored in and
you're good
what we're going for here is peace is
that fair
no sir i appreciate it thank you very
much dude i appreciate you calling
um
yeah i've got high hopes for y'all i
would love to see a dinner
where you
just say sorry
don't bring up anything she's brought to
the table
make it about you so i'm sorry taking a
knee
and i'm gonna do better
and uh
could we set up some things
man that is changing the entire
trajectory of your family
and i'll say it for a third time this
one call
to all the couples listening if you get
in a fight with a purpose to win
i'll show him she needs to i'll tell her
one of you will win and one of you will
lose and you will both lose
every single time
we'll be right back
hey what's up now that my new book own
your past change your future is out in
the wild we've been hearing reviews and
feedback from readers and wow i'm so
grateful and one of the things i've been
most excited about hearing is that this
book is not just for people who are
healing from terrible traumatic
experience or other big scary things
from their past
this book is for everyone in every walk
of life the single 30 year old looking
to sharpen their mind the 25 year old
hoping to make new friends the parent
who's tired of seeing their kids eyes
glued to a screen but who doesn't know
how to re-enter their life people coming
out of abusive relationships
everyone and this book isn't me talking
at you this book is me walking with you
because i've been there too
to better understand and improve your
mental relational and emotional health
please check out own your past change
your future at johndaloni.com today
that's
johndaloney.com today
all right as we wrap up today's show
song of the day i i guess at some point
i said the words wide open spaces
hmm
well that's a famous song everybody from
they used to be called the dixie chicks
now they're called just the chicks
song's called wide open spaces it goes
like this who doesn't know what i'm
talking about who's never left home
who's never struck out to find a dream
and a life of their own a place in the
clouds a foundation of stone
many proceed and many will follow a
young girl's dream no longer hollow oh
this song's about me it takes the shape
of a place out west but what it holds
for her she hasn't guessed she needs
wide open spaces
room to make her big mistakes like
kelly's done jumping on this show she
needs new faces
she knows the high stake way to go
everybody go find your wide open spaces
[Music]